I was so bored in church I'm in church
every Sunday and I'm falling asleep I
can't even stay awake I didn't grow up
in church so I don't have the muscle
that can resist boredom so then when I
started having influence and started
deciding that I'm supposed to affect the
space I started bringing radical changes
that I did not know would have so much
resistance I started working on all the
architecture and changing the designs
and taking out pews and I started using
standup comedy drama film all this made
people like angry I'm like how does this
make people angry we're just creating
Beauty and Artistry and wonder then we
became incredibly diverse and it was a
homogeneous church and now it's Asian
Latino African-American white it's like
it just became an incredible blend